is it a housing block a factory
a bunker from the cold war era the house
of soviets has been part of
kaliningrad's urban landscape for
over 50 years it was 20 years in the
making
then it stood empty for another 30 years
and now this peculiar landmark
is set to be torn down
[Music]
apparently the materials and structure
aren't good enough to keep
and a complete renovation would be far
too costly
it would take about a year to renovate
each floor and there are 21 floors
so it would take about 21 years to
renovate the whole building
the building was supposed to be the
central administration building for the
regional communist party
but nobody ever moved in first
there were structural issues and funds
ran out
then chaos ensued as the soviet union
collapsed
more recently the building has changed
ownership a few times
while slowly falling into disrepair
the street artist show and show is one
of the few who actually uses the
building
though not quite legally which is why he
won't give us his real name
he and other artists have been turning
the concrete surfaces into works of art
we painted and photographed the inside
and the roof at sunset
the atmosphere of a huge abandoned
building in the middle of kaliningrad
is very unusual
not very typical the entire history of
kaliningrad is not very typical for a
russian city either
once a german city it went by the name
of koenigsberg
it was part of east prussia that went to
the soviet union after the second world
war
as the times and inhabitants changed so
did the architecture
the city was looking for a new soviet
identity
the house of soviets was built on the
spot where the koenigsberg castle once
stood
but the attempts to crush a symbol of an
old era
and create a new identity failed the new
building
remained a husk
[Music]
my relationship with the house of
soviets is the same as my relationship
with all the other buildings around
after the war
collective farmers were brought in from
the villages and put in these blocks
they needed a roof over their heads and
people got used to them
but they're hardly
an architecture firm based in st
petersburg has designed a new
development project
that nods to the german past their idea
was to combine housing
and workspaces with stores and cultural
centers
[Music]
we wanted to create a space for citizens
to meet
[Music]
but critics say the design is arbitrary
and faceless
and completely removed from any
historical context
i wouldn't be surprised if they just
ended up building a shopping center
money makes the world go round if it
were up to show and show
the building would stay put and continue
to allow artists
to experiment my idea
was to paint the whole building the
entire facade
but that won't work it would cost a huge
amount of money
but it would be such a cool piece of art
[Music]
the house of soviets is set to be
demolished within a year
about the same amount of time it took
for the soviet union to collapse
and then who knows what the future holds
you